un cas est maintenant sarah abitbol
comme votre bible et stéphane bernadis
mesdames messieurs
dans le bon soir stéphane bernadis
bonsoir soir est vice champion d'europe
et champion de france de patinage et le
2 février dernier vous êtes à salt lake
city pour les jeux olympiques d'hiver
vous entraînez tout va bien tout sauf
une vague douleur au tendon d'achille
pour sarah mais pas de quoi s'alarmer
soudain en tentant une triple boucle
piqué sarah ressent une vraie douleur et
le sou suivant sera fatale là vous
l'apporté jusqu'au vestiaire où elle
hurle en enlevant ses patins rupture
totale du tendon d'achille
bush
[Musique]
oh
donc c'est un rêve qui s'écroule après
vingt ans de patinage je n'avais jamais
été blessé aussi gravement sahara non je
n'ai jamais été blessé quelques petites
entorses avec dix quinze jours d'arrêt
mais vraiment rien de grave
ouais le problème que vous avez stéphane
c'est comme on peut le dire parce qu'on
le sait cet ensemble dans la vie peut
pas trouver une autre équipe hier vous
non et puis j'ai signé avec elle dès le
départ et puis voilà c'est comme ça avec
un shield obligé de le faire avec donc
je m'entraîne tout seul un peu triste
mais c'est comme ça en plus c'est elle
qui vous tire est d'une certaine façon
comme ça mais c'est vrai que non on peut
le dire c'est vrai sarah une plus grande
soif de réussite que vous seul pouvez
toujours aller de l'avant donc c'est
vrai qu'elle est
et les traits meneuse et nous a fait
quand même quelque chose qui se blesse
comme ça vous dit d'ailleurs ça rame a
fait sortir de mon trou grâce à elle je
suis devenu quelqu'un donc pour ça que
je dis ça ouais c'est vrai que fait
sortir de mon trou gilbert professeur
bigard way qui profite du moment où elle
peut pas trop bouger pour faire des
biens moi ça sera fait risi fait le
matin
alors dès votre arrivée à paris vous
avez été admise à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière vous a été opéré par le
professeur saillant
donc je suis qui avait opéré ronaldo
c'est vrai oui j'étais dans la chambre
juste à côté c'était même ça change
c'est dans un mois et demi de plâtre
avant de commencer la rééducation et
vous donnez vous ment absolu vous passez
vos nuits à ses côtés pendant le temps
où elle est à l'hôpital de la
salpêtrière disons que je m'attendais à
vivre le plus beau jour de ma vie et
j'ai vécu le pire
donc c'était très difficile et qu'il
soit à mes côtés à mon chevet lors de
l'opération il était à l'hôpital après
il est resté avec moi toute la nuit
c'était quelque chose moi très bien il
aurait dû manquer que ça qu'il aille
faire la révolte 1 1
oui pu remarquer quand on a touché le
fond on peut que remonter après tout ce
que je me tue bah oui ça peut qu'aller
mieux maintenant je vais remonter bien
sûr on reviendra ici
le problème c'est que c'est
malheureusement pas fini puisque
l'annoncé tardive de votre forfait
aurait permis aurait permis un didier
gailhaguet
le patron de la fédération française de
maintenir la juge française
marie-reine le gougne et c'est elle qui
contre toute évidence a déclaré
les russes vainqueurs au détriment des
canadiens bien conseillé non mais nous
notre problème principal quand sarah été
blessé ça a été de la faire rapatrier
très rapidement parce qu'on nous a dit
qu'elle pouvait pas rester comme ça et
notre forfait
c'est comme si c'était la pédérastie
arena donc à partir de là ce qui
s'occupait aussi tardivement la
déclaration de votre forfait alors
demandé malheureusement n'a pas mâché
gailhaguet oui parce qu'on parle
d'arrangements entre la france vous le
savez entre la france et le bloc de
l'est pour faire gagner le couple
tricolore
gwendal peizerat et marina anissina ce
qui arrive quelques jours plus tard
alors s'est déclenché un scandale énorme
enfin tout le monde tout le monde a
parlé c'est le cas de le dire
protestations du canada enquête les
russes hurle en disant qu'on est revenu
au temps de la guerre froide ça devient
une affaire d'état
ceara armand est en fait autant de
scandales et donc j'espère que tout va
pas se régler parce que ça salit un
petit peu l'image de nos sports qui bien
sûr qui est pourtant magnifique on est
vraiment des on est des vrais sportifs
sont en train de six heures par jour et
c'est dur de se voir en plein dans les
jt entre nous croient qu'il a fait
exprès gailhaguet de pas signifier tout
de suite votre forfait pour pouvoir
garder
marie-reine le gougne qui elle allait
voter évidemment pour les russes qui eux
après aller voter pour les français
franchement
de blizzard et ça c'est clair on peut
pas on ne peut pas on est enfin c'est
pas qu'on n'est pas au courant mais ces
niveaux si l'armée ne peut rien faire on
était dans un contexte qui nous permet
de toute façon ce n'est pas que ça c'est
sûr voilà ils font du sport six heures
par jour
des sportifs se sont pas des businessmen
qui nord mais bon ya eu des pressions
d'ailleurs marie-reine le gougne dit
avoir dans un premier temps albi j'ai
favorisé les russes elle avoue avoir
favorisé les russes sur instruction de
monsieur gailhaguet et après elle s'est
rétractée mais enfin bon il avait subi
des pressions de gaillaguès est
d'ailleurs finalement le cio le comité
olympique international a donné
également une médaille d'or aux
canadiens ça va finir comme chez jacques
martin tout le monde aura 10 seul point
positif de la faire c'est qu'à une
nouvelle façon de juger maintenant donc
au lieu de neuf juges viennent aura 14
c'est mieux c'est moins bien c'est moins
bien vertes ou non donc c'est
l'ordinateur qui choisira l'ordinateur
choisira qu'elle juge ne sont pas
affectés at war du coup les juges ils
pourront très bien mettre une note très
basse on ne dira pas leur nom encore
pire
oui ça permettra à toutes les tricheries
je me suis même pas toutes les
tricheries mais disons que je pense que
l'issue l'international skating l'une a
fait ça pour tourner le pleure de
problèmes avec les juges ne pourra plus
on pourra plus s'en prendre aux juges
pendant et ça a été fait ça en sortant
d'un ordinateur
voilà encore ça circule qu'on a déjà
remboursé c'est la faute aux ordinateurs
mais ça c'est lamentable parce que sur
l'ordinateur il écarte des juges
honnêtes et qu'il garde et cilou ce sera
pire car oui c'est n'importe quoi je
pense pas que je pense j'espère que ça
ne va pas être votée alors faut dire
quand même une chose c'est que derrière
les sourires et les paillettes le
patinage c'est un monde assez dur ça
peut se régler à coups de couteau tu te
souviens de la sphère kerrigan harding
et vous peut dire aussi il ya un an vous
été victime d'un coup de cutter la
veille d'une compétition dans votre
chambre d'hôtel au championnat du monde
à nice voilà déjà en train de regarder
la télé on sonne coups de cutter et
ouvert le bras sans demander que j'ai
pris un coup j'ai la porte s'est
refermée
elle se referme automatiquement et
j'ai vu une silhouette mais
malheureusement j'ai pensé tout était en
place un cutter et depuis plus un coup
de fil plus rien c'est l inde aussi des
plus beau jour de notre vie sportive qui
sont allaités quatrième après le
programme court on jouait le podium
c'était le championnat du monde en
france à nice
donc on se pose des questions c'est
hélas la voilà on voit la nature de
sarah abitbol dit tant pis faut patiner
il faut y aller voilà
et oui j'étais allé vous avez gagné
c'est extraordinaire on vous arrache
donc donc ça va ça s'est arrangé
c'était très bien mais stéphane était à
deux doigts de tout lâcher et l'arrêtent
il n'arrêtait pas de pleurer il m'a dit
comment je vais faire pour te porter
comment j'allais rejouer mais bon on a
fait une piqûre et santé - son bras il a
pu me porter mais c'était vraiment un
moment très très difficile est d'avoir
gagné notre vie c'est un roman
feuilleton la bigue à 48 heures avant
bercy
il est sur un scooter et une gonzesse
qui pile devant lui il tape un nom mais
j'essaye moi j'ai c'est dur mais je suis
très sensible ce qui ce qui est arrivé à
sarah parce que c'est terrible quand
même de se préparer pendant toute une
vie
et puis de se péter deux tendons
d'achille est comme moi je pense que il
faut trouver quelque chose de bien tout
ce qui arrive là j'ai vraiment du mal
pour là je me dis que vraiment ou alors
je me dis ben que c'est vrai que dans
deux ans et on
au top niveau et qui va peut-être y
arriver deux sens on peut plus rien
changer à ce qui s'est passé et on peut
qu on peut pas les annuler les jeux
maintenant c'est trop tard
préval et le temps est maintenant
d'ailleurs on voudrait remercier de sa
rare surface 1 mais moi ça m'a beaucoup
étonné mais des centaines des centaines
de lettres de gens qui nous ont écrit et
donc je voulais leur dire que s'ils
veulent avoir des nouvelles de saramon
un site notre site qui s'appelle
hiver.com ils peuvent
on a des nouvelles tous les jours de
sarah donc voilà je vais vous dire un
truc c'est pour ça que vous êtes là ce
soir je vous ai vu à la télé quand il
est arrivé à l'aéroport j'ai vu votre
tête et j'ai dit à catherine barma faut
vraiment qu'on les invite tout s'est
écroulé d'un coup on s est écroulé sur
le moment c'était vraiment très dur
d'ailleurs d'en reparler c'est difficile
mais bon j'ai mon rêve maintenant c'est
devenir championne d'europe championne
du monde et peut-être championne
olympique en 2006
j'espère que je n'aurai plus mal avec la
niaque que vous avez vous allez y
arriver on va vous applaudir
[Applaudissements]
et stéphane bernadis
bravo
de ferme ça leur a tant dit a pas assez
de force et bien mis la main sur la
chopine est compliqué n'ont pas le choix
sinon tout le monde dans la rue demain
médias président choupinet c'est pas le
bon tu me fais rire c'est ma fille bon
c'est dommage que vous soyez puis au csa
sinon vous ne l'auriez à peu pris là
parce que nouveau saab rire comme
stagiaire pour enregistrer des émissions
de terre 10 et les magnétoscopes
marcherait pas ce jour là bien alors
sahara bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir dans ce mercredi 24
janvier 2001 vous avez gagné la médaille
de bronze des championnats d'europe de
patinage artistique à bratislava
vous avez été devancé par deux couple de
russes comme d'habitude comme dame
ouais enfin ils sont pas imbattables
quand même il irait bien par les avoir
on va les avoir a eu un problème au
changement de musique
voilà il ya une réception un petit peu
difficile après un triple loop lancé je
fais comme si je me connais sur le
triple beaucoup j'ai posé la main
effectivement et ce à nouveau ça nous
vaut peut-être là la place de
vice-champion d'europe mais on
artistique c'est vrai que les juges
n'ont pas pousser non plus parce qu'au
niveau artistique par rapport aux russes
ont été meilleurs mais ils n'ont pas
sorti dès les notes donc il va falloir
encore plus travailler dans les 30
dernières secondes là vous étiez un
petit peu épuisé mon ami ouais ça le
fatigue c'est vrai ne dirait pas comme
ça mais le ps 43 kg s'est pas fatiguant
ouais mais sans arrêt porté par théa oui
mais petit retard sur l'enchaînement de
retard sur vos pas je fais le mec qui
fit que le patinage artistique a fait en
tout cas tu les mines
on a terminé le programme c'est vrai un
petit peu en dedans
il est terminée très très fort on a une
baisse de tension à la fin du pauvre les
nerfs peut-être ces cas bravo mais très
fier de vous c'est la cinquième médaille
de bronze au championnat ça fait
longtemps que je passais les époux
brunet qui avait depuis ya plus personne
à 132 les carpentier oui alors vous
dites on va encore travailler mais vous
travaillez déjà énormément outre les six
heures par jour
vous dites-vous sarah mon programme
c'est pata pata pata pata et kinésie
c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que je crois
qu'il faut une certaine rigueur pour
réussir c'est un sport très très
difficile et
il ya que l'entraînement qui compte et
pour moi tant que j'aurai pas atteint
mon but
là je continuerai c'est bien le milieu
est très dur un bizarrement parce que
c'est vrai que derrière les sourires
derrière les paillettes c'est un domaine
le patinage artistique contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait croire où on se fait
pas beaucoup de cadeaux et en plus quand
ils font du foot ou du rugby ils peuvent
faire des grimaces
vous vous devez sourire ses habitudes on
doit toujours sourire être bien
maquillée bien habillés et costumes tout
ça mais c'est vrai que derrière c'est
ouais c'est la guerre
aujourd'hui il peut y avoir des
accidents très graves cirque un coup de
patin sur la tête c'est le coma cette
attention ça peut être l'amputation
oui ça peut être une paralysie faciale à
des variantes non mais c'est vrai ça
allait mieux
non mais sérieux sa muse ça rigole pas
du tout quoi c'est difficile c'est vrai
que je suis tombé sur un portait il ya
trois ans je suis tombé sur la tête chez
elle à l'hôpital points de suture etc
c'était difficile à gérer et
malheureusement je crois que dans une
carrière c'est c'est sain c'est un sport
où on prend des risques
donc dans une carrière c'est
pratiquement obligatoire qu'il arrive un
accident il faut le dire c'est un sport
où les gens sont pas très sympa entre
eux c'est un sport qui est hyper
dangereux bien aussi des coups de
couteau dans votre dans votre sport
alors tout le monde connaît la sphère
kerrigan harding évidemment les gens se
mettent des coups de couteau et vous
stéphane non mais c'est incroyable cette
histoire 1-1 mardi après-midi vous étiez
à nice comment ça s'est passé la veille
de du jour peut-être le plus important
de ma carrière sportive j'ai été agressé
dans ma à l'entrée de ma chambre d'hôtel
et ça s'est passé en quelques secondes
et alors et alors j'ai j'ai été blessé
mais heureusement pas trop gravement ce
qui m'a permis de patiner le lendemain 2
et de remporter je vous êtes là c'est
l'après midi vous regardez la télé on
sonne à votre porte vous avez ouvrir et
à ce moment là un coup de cutter je
pense que c'est un cutter j'ai pas pu
bien vains mais on a su après que le
type avec fumée du cabanis donc ça le
ferrer je fait d'avoir dû cabanis soit
qui va vous en parler tout qu'est ce que
c'est ça c'est quand on a trop fumée de
cannabis ont dit cabanis alors on vous a
terrible en plus c'est qu'on vous a
accusé d'avoir monté le coup ouais enfin
c'est le problème c'est je pense qu'on
n'a pas bien maîtrisé la chose c'est à
dire qu'il fallait en parler tout de
suite et j'étais tellement concentrée
sur sur la compétition parce que les
médecins m'ont rassuré m'ont dit je
pourrais patiner donc je n'avais qu'un
seul but c'était de réussir mon
programme libre et je me disais qu'après
je ferai le point pour bien expliquer
les choses et si je pense que c'est
l'erreur que j'ai faite et j'aurais dû
faire une conférence de presse
tout de suite après on met les choses au
point alors les gens ont commencé à dire
ah oui or c'est avec une hache c'est
avec un couteau c'est une bouteille de
coca s'était pas de marques à l'antenne
a déjà dit j'ai pas dis kolani cabanis
ni marque
donc voilà ouais c'est l'erreur que
ensuite pendant plusieurs semaines
c'était un peu visité un peu perdu quoi
c'est normal c'est c'est compréhensible
et heureusement vous aider mutuellement
vous êtes très acharné vous êtes la plus
à changer dedans ouais c'est ça dépend
des moments mais c'est vrai qu'à nice
j'étais là pour le soutenir
je voulais pas qu'on déclare forfait
donc
je suis dit écoute on vit un moment
terrible ok mais il faut qu'on patine
ses vingt ans de travail on peut avoir
cette médaille aux championnats du monde
et il faut y aller il faut patiner et il
a patiné mais ça a été difficile on a
failli vraiment déclare forfait non
consentie cabanis vous dit que stéphane
vous a beaucoup pdl vous dites ça rame a
fait sortir de mon trou grâce à elle je
suis devenu quelqu'un vient vous pensez
qu'elle a plus de 2 la niaque que vous
je pense qu on est complémentaires mais
c'est vrai qu'elle a une une soif de
réussir et de toujours aller vers
l'avant même quand tu es tu n'as pas toi
qui es un looser ne provenant pas du
tout mais c'est vrai que quand vous
quand vous êtes rencontrés en 93 vous
étiez pas vraiment au niveau vous
sortiez d'une d'une série d'essais avec
surya bonaly ce n'était pas très très
bien passé
un génial dantin et donc la dent c'est
vrai j'ai eu du mal à mettre au régime
elles ne sont rien parce qu'elle
s'entraînait beaucoup et puis elle
mangeait rien donc
ah ouais mais je devais suivre un petit
peu les mêmes choses j'avais un gros
show avec sa maman et c'était vraiment
pas facile vous êtes un couple sur la
glace et dans la vie alors je peux pas
être indiscret vous savez déjà que c'est
pas le genre de l'émission et mis
combien de temps avant je faisais vu
patiner ensemble au début comme ça il y
avait rien entre vous vous étiez s'est
brisé la glace
bah disons qu'on c'est vrai qu'on
s'entendait bien et puis puis un jour ça
s'est fait naturellement quand il a
glissé il a pénétré
et c'est dangereux le patin président
retour des migrants
je veux continuer mon histoire parce que
s'insinue continue céline histoire
d'amour c'est une histoire alors ils
entraînent de vigiles est-ce que la main
sur la bouche de laurent jeu le temps
que ses fans raconte son histoire
voilà tout simplement on est on est
tombé amoureux comme meilleur vous
dites-vous sarah vous dites j'ai
l'intimé conviction que si on a de si
bons résultats c'est parce que notre
relation intime et forte aux plus beaux
résultats seront bons muscles aux
relations intimes
non mais c'est vrai que cette année on
raconte une histoire d'amour tristan et
iseult et je crois que quelque part
notre histoire d'amour en dehors de la
glace nous est joe comment à
retranscrire cet amour sur la glace vous
êtes un beau couple un tous les deux
dans l'est vraiment alors il ya comme un
problème c'est-à-dire imaginez que vous
disputiez dans la vie comment ça va se
passer sur la glace c'était des images
et ça arrive de se disputer avec sa
compagne son compagnon va disons qu'au
départ c'était une catastrophe c'est à
dire que quand on s'engueulait sur la
glace ou dans la vie courante et bassar
bah oui ça se transmettait et à petit on
met de l'eau dans son vin et puis on va
vous arriver maintenant à dépasser sur
m6 vous engueuler le matin quand vous
patinez vous arrivez à oublier mais on
vit pas ensemble on vit chacun je suis
arrivé chez vos parents voilà je sais ça
ça aide un peu quand même c'est quand on
passe quand même une très grande partie
de leur échapper à la quotidienneté de
l'amour en les raisons mais bon ça va
bien là enfin quoi vous n'êtes pas mal
quand même envie on n'est pas digne
ah les patineurs c'est un lupanar cette
émission au président franchement à quoi
sert le service public moi je me demande
ça sert vous savez quoi services publics
à permettre du patinage artistique à
20h30
voilà quoi ça sert c'est sur france 2
[Musique]
dites moi il y avait une question l'âge
une grille et je suis pour moi une
question c'est un truc que je me demande
tout le temps moi pour moi chaque fois
que je vois un sportif je pose la
question est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut avoir des relations sexuelles la
veille de le jour même puisque le jour
même c'est un handicap non mais sérieux
pour moi je dis obama sarah m'avait dit
tu arrives à nous poser cette question
ah bon alors moi je vais vous demander
jamais le jour de l'émission émission
jamais je garde mon énergie pour mes
amis téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]